bonsoir il était une
à partir
d'il ya plus de cent ans des années 1800
cas
1 les hommes et les femmes ont commencé
à bouger dans le monde beaucoup plus
nombreux qu'auparavant
il y avait beaucoup de raisons qui
étaient politiques mais aussi
économiques qui expliquent que cette
mobilité
cette entrée en mobilité du monde ce
qu'on appelait la première grande vague
migratoire
mon arrière grand père on a fait partie
il a quitté la russie les états baltes
plus précisément et il a décidé de
migrer d'abord en france
ensuite en amérique du sud ils
travaillent dans les chemins de fer
il était de culture allemande il
appartenait à la russie et il a décidé
de consacrer sa vie professionnelle aux
chemins de fer entre le brésil et
l'argentine
mon grand père lui même a été éduqué en
allemand ayant une mère française en
vivant en argentine
mon père a été a fait ses études
scolaires primaires et secondaires aussi
en argentine tout en ayant une mère
française en étant fortement éduqué en
langue allemande et donc on a toujours
jongler avec les langues les pays les
questions de nationalité les questions
de naturalisation les questions de
discrimination aussi est un sujet très
présent dans ma famille et je ne sais
pas si c'est la raison pour laquelle je
me suis consacré au cnrs aux migrations
internationales mais je pense que cette
sensibilité à toutes ces thématiques
peut-être expliquer mon cheminement
scientifique
quand j'ai commencé à travailler
là-dessus tout début des années 80
c'était un minuscule sujet de recherche
surtout en sciences politiques qui est
ma discipline
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu un
sujet global et aujourd'hui on parle
parfois d'ailleurs à tort et à raison de
ces questions en mélangeant beaucoup de
choses et je vais essayer de vous
expliquer toute une série de choses qui
se sont passées
non pas en 1880 même si je vais revenir
rapidement mais aussi aujourd'hui
tout d'abord les migrations elles ont
elles sont venues massive
partir de la fin du 19e siècle parce
qu'on n'a changer de moyen de transport
on est passé dans la deuxième moitié du
19e siècle du bateau à voile au bateau à
vapeur ce qui nécessitait de
rentabiliser les bateaux donc l'europe
notamment était parcourue par des
rabatteurs qui cherchait à trouver des
clients pour que les bateaux les gros
bateaux à vapeur qui partait vers les
etats unis vers l'amérique du sud vers
l'asie ne partent pas à vide et il
fallait donc remplir ces bateaux et ça a
été la première grande vague migratoire
31 millions d italiens par exemple sont
partis en europe mais aussi aux états
unis en amérique du sud les allemands
qui étaient très nombreux pas seulement
dans ce qui n'était pas encore
l'allemagne mais les pays de culture
allemandes sont partis aussi très
nombreux vers les etats unis vers le
brésil vers l'argentine
on a eu aussi des migrations liées à la
colonisation aux comptoirs au commerce
donc le monde commence à bouger à cette
époque
ensuite on a eu les deux guerres
mondiales quelques vagues importantes de
réfugiés de gens qui avaient perdu leur
nationalité qui était venue des
apatrides et aujourd'hui depuis les
années 1990 surtout on en est on est
entré dans une deuxième grande vague de
migration dit de masse c'est ce que vous
voyez sur la carte on a le monde entier
aujourd'hui qu'ils rencontrent le monde
avec les migrations même si quelques
régions du monde
l'europe le japon les pays du golfe ont
du mal à accepter qu'ils sont devenus
des terres d'immigration et c'est un des
grands malentendus que nous avons
aujourd'hui les migrations ne sont pas
si nombreuses puisque ça ne correspond
que à 3 5 % de la population mondiale
240 millions de migrants internationaux
sur sept milliards d'habitants mais 740
millions de migrants intel en revanche
ce que l'on voit c'est que les toutes
les régions du monde sont concernés par
les migrations
aujourd'hui on n'a d'ailleurs plus
de migration vers le sud de la planète
que vers le nord on ne parle quasiment
que des migrations sud nord puisque ce
sont celles qui nous concerne le plus et
aussi on en a des migrations sud nord
sud nord nord donc dans ce contexte on a
des quantités de variétés de migrants on
oublie souvent que les femmes
constituent la moitié des migrants
internationaux que parmi ces migrants on
a des réfugiés dont on a beaucoup parlé
notamment depuis 2015 avec ce qu'on a
appelé la crise des réfugiés eux mais
aussi on a des mineurs non accompagnés
en a des migrations de gens très
qualifiés
on a des migrations environnementales on
a toute une série de nouvelles figures
de migrants qui sont apparus depuis 1990
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé depuis 1990
on a eu une sorte de généralisation du
droit de sortie ça c'est très très
important
pendant très longtemps il était très
difficile de sortir de chez soi
il était une fois il y a un siècle parce
que beaucoup de pays de départ étaient
des pays puissants qu'ils considéraient
que leur population était une richesse
une richesse agricole une richesse
militaire une richesse également fiscale
donc ils maintenaient souvent
relativement fermé et d'autant plus
ferme et qu'ils étaient des régimes
autoritaires leur frontière c'était des
pays puissants les pays où allaient les
migrants s'étaient des pays faibles sur
la scène internationale qui étaient
obligés d'accepter la règle des pays de
départ et ces pays faibles étaient des
pays qui cherchait de la population pour
travailler de la main d'oeuvre mais
aussi pour s'installer pour une
migration de peuplement c'est le cas des
états unis 2 du canada de l'amérique du
sud l'australie et de quantité de
régions du monde
aujourd'hui celle inverse qui s'est
produit il est devenu depuis les années
90 depuis la chute du rideau de fer
beaucoup plus facile de sortir de chez
soi aujourd'hui de presque tous les pays
du monde
on peut sortir sauf peut-être la corée
du nord aujourd'hui même de cuba on peut
sortir aujourd'hui
en revanche il est devenu très difficile
d'entrée quelque part donc le sens des
migrations s'est inversée il est
difficile de d'entrée mais il est facile
de sortir les pays de départ sur des
pays faibles sur la scène internationale
les pays d'accueil sont des pays
puissants qui à travers leurs politiques
migratoires édicte les règles mondiales
de la migration internationale
donc on est dans un couple un contexte
complètement inversé par rapport à celui
des années 1880 celle à laquelle mon
grand par exemple a décidé de quitter
des états baltes qui était à l'époque la
russie
ces migrations elles sont devenues
structurelles c'est à dire que pendant
notamment on a tendance à considérer que
la migration c'est quelque chose qui a
su revient de temps en temps et qu'il
faut accepter parce qu'on a signé
quelques accords notamment les retraités
la convention de genève donc de 1951
pour l'asile et donc les pays européens
à des périodes diverses depuis la guerre
froide puisque c'était la guerre froide
1951 ont accueilli des vagues de
réfugiés plus ou moins bien avec plus ou
moins de de frilosité mais il faut
accueillir les réfugiés
en même temps il ya eu des périodes où
manquer de main d'oeuvre c'était la
période dite des trente glorieuses en
europe 1945 1974 on avait besoin de main
d'oeuvre on faisait venir des gens mais
l'europe s'est aperçu que beaucoup de
ces gens qui étaient accueillis ne
repartez pas alors qu'on pensait que ce
serait conjoncturelle aujourd'hui la
migration elle est structurelle elle
correspond à des grandes tendances du
monde qui sont les notamment les
inégalités du développement humain que
l'on voit sur cette carte qui montre
tout particulièrement l'afrique
subsaharienne parmi les plus grandes
régions d'inégalités du développement
humain qui croise trois critères
essentiels qui sont ceux d'un prix nobel
d'économie a dit
un qui s'appelle amartya sen l'espérance
de vie à la naissance le niveau
d'éducation le niveau de vie est donc
aujourd'hui les gens ne sont plus dans
la fatalité des anciens ils n'attendent
plus que des jours meilleurs se passe
ils se disent si je veux réaliser mon
projet de vie
il n'y a que la migration les gens sont
de plus en plus scolarisés de plus en
plus urbain de plus en plus informés ils
sont branchés très souvent non seulement
sur la télévision mais sur internet et
sur le téléphone portable et donc ils
savent que ailleurs on peut vivre
autrement donc la migration elle est
dans toutes les têtes des pays du sud
s'il considère que chez eux il n'y a
aucun espoir de vivre autrement et même
parfois chez eux c'est la guerre et donc
il faut partir donc on a eu ce phénomène
qui s'est accélérée depuis ces trente
dernières années de façon structurelle
avec d'autres phénomènes qui ont ajouté
à cette tendance structurelle du monde
qui est la démographie
on est dans un monde où au nord on a une
population vieillissante comme on le
voit les pays qui souvent en verre ou en
jaune clair
c'est le cas aussi de la russie c'est le
cas du japon également pas seulement de
l'europe
et puis au sud on a des pays qui sont
jaunes qui sont ce qu'on appelle la
transition démographique en une
génération
dans la plupart des pays du pourtour
méditerranéen y compris dans des pays
d'islam
contrairement à une idée répandue on a
eu une transition très rapide de la
taille des familles on est passé de 6
enfants par femme à 2,5 enfants par
femme dans l'ensemble du pourtour euro
méditerranéen surtout méditerranéens du
sud
ce qui change complètement la donne
puisque aujourd'hui on a une population
jeune dans cette région de l'âge médian
l'âge moyen qui sépare en deux groupes
égaux la population ses 25 ans en
afrique subsaharienne 19 ans et en
europe c'est
quarante ans donc ça c'est une donnée
très profondes qui explique aussi cette
volonté de partir de la part de gens
pauvres de la part de gens jeunes qui
sont en meilleure santé mieux informés
autre élément structurel c'est les
grandes inégalités les grandes lignes de
fracture du monde chaque fois qu'on a
des lignes de fracture politique
économique sociale culturelle la
migration atténue par sa mobilité
c'est ligne de fracture et propose donc
une nouvelle donne c'est le cas de la
méditerranée c'est le cas de la
frontière entre les etats-unis et le
mexique entre les pays d'europe et ses
voisins entre les pays riches et les
pays pauvres de l'asie et puis le
contexte dans lequel on migre est très
différent selon son passeport et ça
c'est une des grandes inégalités du
monde aujourd'hui il y à un mouvement
toute une série de tentatives de forums
qui essaye de dire il faut promouvoir le
droit à la mobilité comme droits de
l'homme du xxième siècle si vous êtes
européens ou américains vous pouvez
voyager pour trois mois dans 174 pays
dans le monde où 173 selon votre
passeport
si vous êtes russe dans 91 pays si vous
êtes erythréens somaliens vous ou sous
délai pour que si vous représentez ce
qu'on appelle un risque migratoire et il
n'y a que les passeurs qui peuvent vous
permettre de circuler parce que vous ne
pouvez entrer nulle part donc un moment
où aujourd'hui on considère que la
mobilité fait parti de la modernité
seule une toute petite partie de la
population du monde peut bouger alors
que les deux tiers de la population de
la planète sont finalement assigné à
résidence chez eux dans des pays où il
ne fait pas très bon vivre en général
avec des guerres civiles avec des crises
avec toute une série de forme de
prédation économique
et puis avec une population qui est de
plus en plus consciente que la seule
façon de s'en sortir
ces deux parts
tire donc voilà un peu le contexte dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui avec les
migrations et il faut essayer de
comprendre ce phénomène qui est une
réalité on peut être pourrait on peut
être contre mais c'est une réalité qui
fait partie des grands enjeux de ce
siècle
[Applaudissements]